تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
المشهدا مؤثرا لوداع النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو وهو يغادر باكيا بعد
خساره البرتغال امام المغرب وضياع اماله
بالفوز بكاس العالم قبل الاعتزال
[موسيقى]
اثاره مقطع فيديو عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي حاله من الجدل بعد ظهور احد
الاشخاص يشبه الشيخ محمد متولي الشعراوي
وظهر شبيه الشيخ الشعراوي داخل ساحه احد
المساجد بينما تجمع حوله عدد كبير من
الاشخاص للالتقاط صور التذكاريه وارتدى
شبيه الشعراوي الملابس نفسها والنظاره
الشمسيه التي كان يستخدمها الشيخ بل واطلق
اللحيه لتكون مشابهه للشيخ الراحل
ضجه واسعه بين لبنانيين اثارها توقيف
الممثله اللبنانيه ستيفاني صليبه للتحقيق
معها في ملف الاسراء غير المشروع وتبييض
الاموال المرتبط بحكم المصرف المركزي رياض
سلامه وكيله اعمال ستيفاني اكدت اطلاق
سراحها مع تركها رهن التحقيق فيما ذكرت
وسائل واعلام اللبنانيه تلقي صليبا هدايا
باهظه مفترضه من سلامه كما اكدت استدعائها
من قبل السلطات اللبنانيه كشاهده في اطار
تحقيق حول ثروتي سلامه